what greater Black Friday gift then a
David Pakman show calendar I'm kind of
kidding you know that for me tomorrow
Black Friday is what I like to call by
nothing day I'll probably just hang out
at a coffee shop and support a local
business but I will not be participating
in this this horrible horrible thing
called Black Friday but if you're
starting to plan on gifts for people or
you want to get yourself something for
the new year we have the 2017 david
pakman show calendar this contains all
original art it is a wall calendar and
I'll show you in a little more detail
some of the really great artwork from
Dan Burke this is the cover you will see
that we have me as the referee of a
boxing match by the way no gloves boxing
match between Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump we see Jeb in the background we
see Obama in the background we see other
people in the background Rachel too I
think Rachel is in the background there
she seems shocked by what's going on
here we also have the Great's what's
next we have the back cover that we
could show people or the last image this
is the last image it's me with a beard
it is me shirtless rachel is there Trump
is there jeb Bush's there Hillary Ted
Cruz ben Carson Larry can you see here
what's up Larry King is there where is
Larry King I towards the bottom on the
right bottom right oh yeah that Larry
King hiding behind Rachel's shoulder and
then lastly here's one of the comic
strips that is on one of the months this
is a zoom in of a couple of the panels
this is Lois and Pat Robertson conjuring
demons apparently on the internet or
something like that or no it's a record
player it's a record player that they're
using to conjure demons and I show up
every single month has an original piece
of political or david pakman show
related artwork this is the best
calendar we've ever done and I really
would like it if you grabbed one a few
options you can get just the calendar
signed or not signed at david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 if you have been
thinking about getting a membership I
will send you the calendar for free if
you sign up for membership through the
link at david pakman.com slash calendar
17
when you're done with the Thanksgiving
Day festivities if you are celebrating
or partaking or if you're really bored
because you watch American political
shows and you live in another country
and because it's Thanksgiving there's a
lot of people with days off today
what better activity than getting a
David Pakman show calendar grab them we
will be back with so much new content
for you starting on Monday